foreign
it's time for everybody's favorite
segment facts are your friends let's do
it
I'm not gonna comment on how terrible
this music is am I gonna say a word
about it I'm just gonna plow through
Kelly I got this
a psychology expert shares the seven
toxic signs of highly insecure people
and how to deal with them and this
article is grade a dog crap alright so
uh here we go a psychology expert this
is going to be great
hey
that word gives me hemorrhoids now all
right so March 1st 2023 who came out
says working with difficult
personalities can dampen our ability to
think clearly and make sound decisions
that's how this article starts working
with difficult personalities can dampen
our ability to think clearly and make
sound decisions I reject this premise
wholeheartedly
no one can control my ability
to think or make sound judgments unless
number one they break me like I think uh
it's the purpose of hell week with with
Navy Seals they want to like no sleep
constant physical exercise constant
people screaming yelling at you they
want to push you past a point where you
are have any ability to think they've
taken that from you you sign up for it
but they take it from you and then they
want to see who you are on the back side
of that right so someone can break you
or number two you give it to them
you give it to them
that's it
I work with I've worked with difficult
people my whole career and when I find
myself unable to think clearly or make
sound decisions it's because I've got
caught up in their drama I have handed
them keys to my life I've become like
Dawson's Creek character like oh what's
happening now it's all on me it's on me
I reject this premise that other people
can control my life that way now let's
keep going
um then the person tells how great they
are and how smart they are and blah blah
through my research I found that
insecure people are often the most
difficult to deal with agreed insecure
people are very tough to be in
relationship with and I will also say
that most of the time that insecurity
comes if I'm their boss because I'm not
being clear at all or if I work for them
I have created an anxious life so much
so that I owe so much money in student
loans I
um am so desperate to meet my own
insecure ego needs with a job title or a
salary number I've created a work I have
to live in this city and if I don't live
in this city it's ridiculous and all my
dreams is
so I have to I mean I'm in servitude to
this boss so either I'm a boss working
with these folks and I'm not clear and
so they get this insecurity or I'm
insecure because I'm working for or I'm
working for an insecure boss but I don't
have another option I've boxed myself
into a corner
um and I I live in these this soap opera
but I'll agree I'll agree working with
this group people is very tough whether
you're their boss or they're your boss
right
insecure types are extremely risk-averse
and unproductive some can be downright
nasty or display abusive behaviors
then they should be fired
if somebody is abusive in the workplace
or they are downright nasties this
article says
you shouldn't have a seven step strategy
for dealing with them they should be
fired they shouldn't work there anymore
because they're destructive
psychologically emotionally you're gonna
make less money with your business
because you have these kind of morons
running around and the whole culture is
going to go to hell it's just it's
ridiculous or
I'm not gonna work for you
and I have left
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars on the table and walked out the
door
on a couple of different a couple of
different times throughout my career
because I'm not going to work with an
insecure boss who is always using me to
fill in gaps in their soul I'm not gonna
do it
I'm not gonna do it I I
it's not worth it over the Long Haul I'm
not going to give you a stroke I'm not
going to give you my heart attack I'm
not going to give those things to you
I'll let my I'll give those to my kids
and my wife I'm not going to give those
away all right so um they say the most
common toxic behaviors he says the most
common toxic behaviors are overly
concerned about what others think of
them never express a firm opinion suffer
from chronic inability to make decisions
even when choices have little
consequence they frequently try to
change the direction of projects or
meetings they put other people down to
make themselves look more important they
constantly talk about how busy they are
when they actually aren't
um to show that they're in demand
they're paranoid meddlers who make who
question your every move
let's let's distill some of this down
um
we are so caught up in in I'm talking to
my own psychological Community now we're
so caught up in our fancy little labels
let's say what this is
this is somebody who's abusive somebody
who's a liar
and somebody who is displaying highly
narcissistic traits
so let's don't say like it's somebody
with um insecure attachment but no this
is a Jerk It's a Jerk It's a person
who's not telling the truth who is using
other human beings as punching bags to
make themselves feel tough
and when there's power differentials in
a workplace it's even worse because that
person sometimes is trapped right so it
goes on how to handle insecure people
as little as possible I don't handle
people
I just don't like that language
um it it acts like we are all Hannibal
Lecter like we're all playing our own
little marionette God game where it's
like I'm handling this person I'm
handling this person I I'm you've been
like I've found out that I was getting
handled like Hey we're gonna have a
meeting to figure out who's gonna tell
John this thing uh dude it made me
insane just come tell me and if I'm a
person who can't hear that I should be
fired I shouldn't work here and if
you're a person who can't tell me you
shouldn't I don't you know you should so
all I have to say is this
how to handle take that out
either you're with people or you aren't
with people okay let that be a a way to
operate now there's certain things I
don't say around certain people there
are certain like um I'm just not gonna
have that conversation I'm not gonna
talk theology with that person I'm not
going to talk psychology this person
it's just it's just not I'm not going to
talk about covert with this person it's
just so if you want to call that
handling fine but I just think that's
being wise
um but here we go how to handle insecure
people
and again this article is called a cycle
socks ugh
a psychology expert shares the seven
toxic signs of highly insecure people
and how to deal with them and this so
far this article's worth
um if you fold it in half it will be
worth two ply all right so the first
step is how to activate your detective
mindset
you know what you shouldn't ever do
activate your detective mindset
Sherlock Holmes turning turn interacting
with insecure people into a learning
opportunity oh gosh all right some of
these I agree with actually I agree with
them I'm gonna be honest where I can be
honest and some of them I think they're
insane number one assess the size of the
problem yes
are all these interactions bad or is
this person just kind of annoying over
here fine let's move on with your days
this person one of those people that
always has to claim credit no matter
what fine I I'm not gonna lose a second
of sleep over that if they're dishonest
and they're stealing my ideas and
they're putting them forward and they're
getting paid for that whatever that's a
different conversation but again I'm
just gonna go to handle that directly
I'm just gonna go talk to them directly
um so assess the size of the problem is
this a huge deal or a little deal that's
good
number two identify the root causes of
the problem no the world does not need
any more pseudo-psychologists we got too
many people
using Google to diagnose each other and
to try to solve clinical issues in the
workplace stop stop
I don't even try to do this I don't I I
don't have any interest in like a little
into this person's got anxiety right
this person's really rude and I'm gonna
close the door and say hey you can't
it's not okay for you to talk to me that
way and at this hour we're going to
communicate then let me know because I
need to make some decisions then not
like oh well I wonder what's the root
cause here I'm not gonna do that
number three cultivate genuine
compassion yes all of us always
that that person who's insecure is
somebody's kid
at one time they were a little kid
and whatever series of things happen to
them over the course of their life has
led them here is there an excuse no is
it a context absolutely
compassionate be compassionate
um over invest in one-on-ones no it's
over it's reinforcing now every single
leader and supervisor should have a
one-on-one meeting every week with their
staff maybe every two weeks at the most
with their direct reports there's gotta
be that human connection there and
unfortunately it can't be done over
email I don't think I have not seen it
successful
um you gotta get in a room and meet you
gotta go grab coffee together those
things are all good but the idea that
this person is a little more insecure so
I've got to over invest there
number one times finite number two your
team will quickly know that you're
favoring this person number three that
person's Behavior becomes rewarded
psychologically it becomes a reinforcing
context for oh if I act like this I get
more time with supervisor I get more
relational needs right
number five have an exciting outcome in
mind I'm not even gonna dignify that
with a response
um that gives me diarrhea on top of the
hemorrhoids number six be transparent in
how you communicate yes
it says it goes on to say and this is
true insecure people have a tendency to
see gaps in arguments yes absolutely
punch holes in everything yes because it
gives them a an opportunity to not make
a decision cool clear
clear
I am certain about this is what I
believe I'm very clear there is no there
is no ambiguity here this is the way and
most of us don't like that most of us
don't like to speak like that we don't
like to lead like that we just say
things like hey man be cool I don't even
know what that means hey man uh like
this we start at 10 30. you know if you
are late again you will be fired
that's clear
and I see Kelly pointing at me right now
that hurts my feelings Kelly that makes
me insecure
um number seven fill in the gaps
together
um yeah that's I mean
there's a
they shouldn't just be for Instagram
people should be for everybody everybody
in your organization should have a sense
of ownership from the person sweeping
the floors to the person
um uh purchasing things to the person
selling things to the CEO everybody's
got ownership in this how this thing
works and everybody plays a part in the
person who's getting served on the back
end of this thing
um number eight work in increments
that's scaffolding I can see that being
positive
um especially at the beginning of
projects absolutely number nine show
that you are not a threat no
because I might be
if you continue to not show insecure
issues if you're not insecure now but if
you lie
if you bully other people if you
constantly distract a meeting and and
make us where we can't get our work done
you're not gonna work here very long
or I'm not gonna work for you very long
I'm gonna seek to create a world where I
can exit this as soon as possible
because this this this rubs off on my
family life this rubs off on my personal
life this rubs off on my psychology and
my physiology it rubs off on everything
I'm not gonna do it I'm not going to
subject myself to that just so I can
have some fancy job title or I can have
some dollar amount it's not gonna do it
I'm not and I implore you out there
listening don't don't put up with this
so
um show that you're not a threat no I'm
not I I might be a threat I might ask
you to not work here anymore if if you
weren't for me or I guess it's not
threatening I might just leave right
um this says pay compliments and Express
gratitude I admire what you do and I'm
excited to continue learning from you no
don't do that it just reinforces the
behavior it just makes this insecure
monster stronger not doing it here's
that don't participate walk away
walk away
oh
Kelly I
asked me to tell you what I thought
that's what I think is that good
I think you've been fairly clear yeah I
don't think there's a lot of ambiguity
here